If you came here to have a bunch of
points like swirl around each other like
it's some sort of fluid and there's
vortices and blah blah blah, you came to
the right place. But there is a cost to
getting this very cool effect and that
is a lot of confusion. A lot of math and
a lot of confusion. The idea of this
tutorial is going to be called curl. So
what you're going to be learning is
curl. Get ready to learn curl. This
video is sponsored by Squarespace and
we're going to talk about that later. I
want you to imagine we have a grid of
points which we know how to make. I'm
going to make a grid right here. So
let's say we have a 100 by 100 points.
That's 10,000. These in themselves need
to be points, not vertices as part of a
geometry. And I want you to imagine that
I take these points and I want to move
them on every single frame. The way I
would approach that is I would add a
simulation zone that update can be
moving the points. So let's set position
by some offset, which I'm going to use a
noise texture for. Turn off normalize.
When I do that, it's crazy. We do the
next logical thing. We take this, we
scale it such that maybe it's only
moving 1% as strong as it was. And
you're going to see there's all of this
bunching. And that is going to be the
thing we are combating here. So the
points, they swirl kind of, but they
eventually over time kind of go into
these lines. This cluster over here, for
example, is going to shrink to a single
point over time. There's some areas that
are repelling. So if I look at this area
over here, it just kind of expands
outwards. And this is what we call
syncs, which means points moving into an
area and sources or emitters, points
moving far away from it. To get a curl
field, everything moving around each
other, we need to take the divergence,
which is saying, is there a sync? Is
there a source? And we need to get rid
of it. This tutorial is about that. How
do we get rid of divergence so that
everything swirls? It avoids each other
rather than shrinking or emitting,
expanding. I want you to imagine we have
a vector field V. In this case, we used
V as like a noise texture and that in
itself is composed of a X component, Y
component and Z component. What I want
to do is I want to create something
called a curl field, which is this.
Yikes. This notation, what it means is
we are calculating the curl. This kind
of like swirly thing we're trying to
achieve of V. It's actually the
determinant of a matrix with derivatives
and components. And I want you to ignore
that. This can be simplified to a very
much more simple version. It looks
longer but it is simpler. So again the
curl of a field is now composed of three
components. An x component, a y
component and a z component. So for the
x component for example all we have to
do is we take our vector field v. We
isolate the z component and I check how
does that change as y changes. I take
that I subtract it from the y component
and I ask how does that change relative
to z. And and don't get me wrong I
understand this is confusing. If you're
confused this isn't like an advanced
Khan Academy video. Remember, our goal
is to take a bunch of points on a 2D
plane and swirl them around each other.
It is constricted to a two-dimensional
thing, which means we can take our curl
and assume that the output needs to also
be two dimensional, which is a major
saving. If we only want a x and a y
component, what that means is that the
curl has to have a z component over here
of zero. That way, there's only an x and
a y. And one very simple way to do that
is we assume that the y component of our
vector field and the x component of our
vector field are always zero. That way
the derivative is zero and it subtracts
out to be zero. We get rid of all this.
We also look at this y component section
over here. We see there's a x component
over here. We can get rid of that. And
we see a y component over here. And we
can get rid of all of that. Super super
long story short. If we pick a vector
field v that could be a noise whatever
such that it only has a z component. no
x or y. We can easily take this magical
curl thing and it will be equal to
something very simple. Okay, now let's
get to stuff we kind of understand. Geo
nodes land. We need to first of all have
a noise that only has a Z component as
we talked about. So I'm going to take a
noise texture node. Super simple. And I
want this to only have a Z component. So
I'm going to take the color which has
XYZ, red, green, blue, and I'm going to
multiply it by 0 01. So, in other words,
this takes in a position and it will
send it to something with only a Z
component. Now, because we're going to
be using this all the time, I'm going to
turn this into a node group. Yes, we can
use the new bundles and closures, but
let's keep it not having another complex
thing. Ctrl G to make it a node group.
It's going to output this vector over
here. And by the way, I'm using 5.0,
which is why it has this nice new
design. Maybe let's just call it V.
Super simple. In other words, we have
achieved this. Beautiful. Remember, the
next thing we need to do is compute the
curl of this special case. And we know
all we need to do is take the derivative
of this with respect to y with respect
to x and then for some reason make the x
negative. So how do we take the
derivative of this with respect to y?
Well, I want you to imagine this
represents our vector field. It's dark
in some places, it's bright in others.
So for example, let's say we're sampling
at this point here. To kind of get the
slope or the derivative of it, all I
need to do is kind of nudge it a little
bit in this direction. I evaluate it. So
now I have our initial point and one
where I moved it a little. That's going
to have some difference. and then I
divide it by this gap over here. If you
think of this as kind of like a
landscape that goes up and down as I
sample position along the y. If I want
to know the derivative right here, which
is going to tell us the slope, right?
Like is that going downhill or uphill?
The way we approximate this cuz we don't
know it exactly. I look at this point
over here. I sample one really, really
close. I look at their difference in
value, how much it went up or down. I
then look at how much of a nudge I did.
And then you divide the two. That will
give you the slope of a line that will
very very well approximate that uh
derivative. And we can do that on x and
on y. Easy money. I'm going to take
this. I'm going to duplicate it. This
one instead of having the position, I'm
going to nudge it a little on the x. So
I am going to add a very tiny number
like 01. So this v is the vector field.
And then this v over here represents the
vector field when we nudged it a little
bit. We now take the difference, how
much did it change, which is going to be
some value. And then we divide by how
much did we move which will give us that
nice slope. What do we divide by? We
divide by however much we shifted it. So
in this case it's 0.001.
And this output over here is the
derivative with respect to x. So we are
done. So let's get the one with respect
to y. It's just a simple right. So I'm
going to take another one of these over
here. I'm going to again nudge the
position but this time just moving it a
little on the y-axis and set this to
zero. And to get the derivative with
respect to y, we take our original
vector field. We subtract by what
happened when we nudged it just a little
on the y-axis. And then finally, we
divide by how much of a gap we moved by.
Now, let's do our victory lap. I'm going
to take all of this and turn it into a
node group. I want to know the x
derivative and the y derivative of our
vector field that only has a z
component. It's fine. And we can call
this new node group maybe our
derivatives. The nice thing about this,
and this is kind of like how closures
work, but we're not going to do that
yet, is if I go into my vector field V,
I can change the noise however much I
want, and it's going to update these
derivatives. I guess one modification I
want to make is remember our vector
field, whatever it may be, only has a Z
component, which means when we subtract
by stuff and divide by stuff, it's going
to be something, but it's still only
going to be a Z component. Maybe I can
just separate XYZ, giving this Z
component, cuz that's all we care about
ultimately. And then I'm going to take
these and turn them into floats so that
we're saying I already isolated the Z
component. Okay, beautiful. We're ready
to construct the curl field. The sponsor
of this video is Squarespace and that's
actually on the mind for me because over
the last week I've been doing a overhaul
redesign of my website cggatter.com so
that it's better for members and has
like free nodes now. It also has a blog
that talks about how I worked for
Corridor Digital for like 2 weeks if you
want to read that. and that redesign
process was super easy to do because of
Squarespace's features and just UI. Some
things to know is that they have a
payment platform integrated right into
the service. So, if you have a digital
product or a member site, you don't need
to outsource payment. It can all be done
in one convenient place. And then for
assets being images, videos, whatever it
might be, Squarespace comes with an
asset library. So, you can again put it
all in one place. Thirdly, if you're
writing I I guess it depends on you, but
for example, if I'm writing
documentation, Squarespace has
integrated AI that can fill in the
details that I know what is correct and
then I can quickly verify. You can just
head over to Squarespace and make a
website. And when you want to launch it
and make it live, you can use this link
below in the description to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain. Made it very easy to redesign
cg.com. So remember, we combine XYZ.
Let's look at it one more time. So it's
the derivative with respect to y and
then minus with respect to x with
respect to y. Can really get lost here
with all these x's and y's and
derivatives but whatever minus. So I'm
going to multiply this by negative 1
with respect to x and then remember the
z component is zero because all of this
is going to be the curl of v. We are
done. So let's take all this make it a
node group and I'm going to call all of
this curl which I guess should output
the vector. So long long long story
short, we have a vector field V and
whatever we do to it, however we modify
it, which I'm going to disable normalize
just so it's like centered. Whatever we
do to this, change the scale, whatever,
we now have a curl field for just X and
Y. So maybe I'll call it curl XY. And
now for the punch line, let's actually
move these points and make some kind of
artsy art. What could the art look like?
Well, let's start off with a mesh grid.
We already demoed this, so let's do 200
by 200. These need to be points, not
vertices in a mesh. So, I'll turn these
into points, which we can make much
smaller so we can see them. So, just
tiny radius. I think something like this
is much nicer to uh look at. So, I have
my points. And what do I want to do with
them? I want to push them over time with
a simulation zone. So, just like before,
we have a simulation zone. We feed in
the points, move those points on every
single frame by what quantity, like how
am I offsetting it? By our curl xy. And
this in itself will swirl, but it's
going to be chaotic. Like boom. I don't
know if you can even see that. Probably
not. It just kind of exploded. It is
working. It's just really, really
strong. We can scale it. In other words,
make it smaller by either a really tiny
number like 0.01, which in itself is
still way too fast, or we can use delta
time and multiply it by something up to
you. I'm going to do 0.001.
And even that's pretty fast moving. You
can see it's starting to curl, but it
still looks like it has that divergence.
So, let's make it even 10 times slower.
see what that looks like. And now I
think you're starting to see it. Points
aren't really bunching together or
expanding, but rather they are swirling
around each other in this way that
preserves, I don't know, it preserves
density in a way. There's zero
divergence. The only thing that's kind
of weird is we have some water, if you
want to think about it that way, exiting
the square system we started off with.
Instead of 200 by 200, let's do 400 by
400. And now you can really start seeing
that swirl. Look at that. So here you
have like a vort a vortex of vorticy and
it's really moving like water where
everything pushes everything else
instead of uh those sinks we talked
about. Yeah. Outside of it you can see
some nice like swirls forming and stuff
like that. And remember um because we
constructed it the way we did. All of
this can be modified by just changing
the vector field. So we can have it move
differently. So if I choose a scale of
15, it's still going to work but now we
have a bunch of tiny vortices that all
kind of curl on each other. But note
that because there's now more micro
detail, those derivatives need to be
more accurate. So inside of our curl,
I'm going to go inside of our
derivatives and maybe make this 0.001
number 10 times smaller. Gets a really
good approximation here. So we change
that, which means we also have to change
these numbers over here. And we can
mitigate that even more by taking how
much it moves and scaling it down. Now,
uh you're going to notice that while
this works, we're going to get to the
point where it's moving really, really
slowly, which needs to be done to
preserve the accuracy, but I want it to
visually be faster. What if we take
super small steps like we are doing
right now, but we do multiple steps
every frame? In other words, we're
turning steps into substeps. Wouldn't
that be nifty? Well, it would be nifty.
So, let's actually do that. Throw in a
repeat zone inside of here. So, for
every frame, every simulation frame, I'm
going to do an operation multiple times.
Specifically, it's going to be this set
position offsetting. The only thing I'm
going to change is I'm going to make the
step size super small cuz we can afford
to. Now, for now, we're doing one
iteration. It's going to be accurate,
but so, so slow. So, let's do five
iterations per frame. It's going to
preserve that accuracy, but now on every
frame, it's going to move more, but at
the cost of more computation. It's at
this point that we probably want to bake
our simulation instead of kind of going
frame by frame. So, simulation nodes,
hit uh bake, and we'll let that do its
thing. And just like that, we get a very
accurate curl field where there's very,
very minimal divergence. There's these
nice swirls over here. And then what you
do with it is the artistic part. I just
wanted to talk about the technical part
because jeez, it's complicated. And if
we want to eventually make a fluid
simulator, which we do because of the
new grid 3D stuff, we're going to have
to be using this curl. So turning this
into a node group is critical. Before
signing off here, let's take advantage
of the fact that we have a algorithm, a
recipe to take any vector field and make
it a curl field. So let's take the noise
and maybe replace it with something. I
wonder what a wave texture would look
like. And h I mean technically that's
kind of interesting. If it's kind of
going on a wave, the only way to avoid
compression is by going outward. So
notice these points are still flowing
around each other. Let's do one that
looks better though. Well, we have our
magic texture which has more interesting
like two dimensional stuff going on. So
I'm just going to connect that here.
Increase the depth. And nice diversions
free flow while still kind of
maintaining the shape of it. And it
makes these cool like bands over here.
This would be a good time to use the
voronoid texture. Not the color or the
position cuz those are just constant
values per cell but maybe the distance
would look good. Interesting. So now you
have this flow that's kind of
constrained to the cells which means it
would kind of have to swirl to avoid
divergence. Very interesting. You ready
for a super cool one? So here I did my
sine waves through X and Y and added
them together. So the only way it can
avoid divergence is by making all of
these whirlpools. I mean come on. That's
super cool. What happens if I make one
of them a tangent? I don't even know.
Okay, new patterns unlocked. So, what
did we learn today? What's the takeaway
of all this? Well, we learned that
avoiding divergence, like where noise
shrinks or compresses or whatever, is
really hard to do, or one obvious way to
do it is to take the curl of a field cuz
that ensures that it has no divergence.
I'm sure there's other ways to generate
them. Moving around points is actually
kind of the obvious way to visualize it,
but you could totally like do anything
with it. You can move around strings.
You can use it as a rule for how much to
extrude things, whatever. So, the
project files of the renders you see are
going to be available on cgmatter.com
for members. Blend files at
cgmatter.com. Thank you for watching.